generally I think a lot of people
already kind of know what I'm kind of
what I'm alluding to but we've we've
known that there's been been interesting
um correlations between nuclear
technology capabilities whatnot and and
UAP activity so clearly if you can
create an environment
where you can potentially attract these
things then you can probably collect
more data on these things and so
you know they're in lies part of the key
if you can create a situation where
maybe you these things come because
they're interested in what you have
then you can you can collect information
that's about as much as I'm prepared to
say right now but I think a lot of
people kind of know historically if you
look at uh Robert Hastings book uh the
the nukes and UFOs
um you know it's there's a lot of
compelling data in there
John you have anything to add to that
I mean I'll throw some some uh some
redneck metaphors out there and say you
don't go to Alabama to catch a
hippopotamus
I see yes Nick D says over the time
frame that you researched to investigate
a uaps did you see the uaps improve like
faster speeds more daring Maneuvers
capabilities over time in other words
other words is there evidence that their
technology has advanced
it's it's one of those it assumes that I
have observed you know it assumes a lot
but um nope
not in my lifetime I can't even say what
their technology truly does
so it's a hard question to answer
yeah same to me Lord with me I haven't I
haven't seen any any indicators that
their technology has has changed or
necessarily improved a lot of the the
observations we see now are the same
ones that were made in the in quite
frankly in the 60s and even the 50s
Blaine toterian asks in the GQ interview
Lou you mentioned that a pilot
experienced 30 minutes go by on his
watch but only consumed five minutes of
fuel in his jet did you happen to find
any corroborating evidence in the form
of fuel log discrepancies or
chronographic anomalies on the jet any
tips for forming a foia request on this
yeah there's there's actually been been
several experiences like that reported
by by eyewitnesses uh military sources
there's one very compelling I won't say
the person's name uh but he was on a
Mountaintop and
um felt like just a few minutes went by
and uh five hours had gone by uh you
know this is the whole missing time
right uh peop the observation that some
people report to have that that uh what
appeared to be just a few minutes in
reality was much much longer and there's
also a lot of reporting from foreign
Pilots as well and foreign military
personnel so this isn't just a U.S thing
there's other individuals who have have
experienced this as well the problem is
very hard to reconcile
um because you know at some point
human observation is subjective you know
um and uh
I think I think we have to be careful I
think it's a data point but as as Sean
likes to say all the time at the end of
the day it's just a data point
um you know it we it's it's in the
collection of many many data points that
allows us to create a much more
comprehensive picture so I'm always
careful not to just use a single data
point and that's why from the perceptive
perspective of atip the observables were
so important because you had five
distinct actually six distinct
observables that when put together
painted a very compelling picture you
know one could say well we have
Hypersonic vehicles or we have vehicles
I can do instantaneous acceleration or
low observability
but we don't have one that can do all
five right and so that's when it becomes
very compelling and the same thing with
the with the biological effects in this
case if you have missing time then then
that is potentially biological or a
psychological effect and that's
something that you now see in the in the
law you know we have to we have to
report on biological effects